Kohls Mädchen Mutti Madame no leader of
the free world an Angela Merkel kleben
viele Etiketten wir haben uns an sie
gewöhnt und ob man sie nun mochte oder
nicht ihr Lebenslauf von der
ostdeutschen Pfarrers Tochter zur
mächtigsten Frau der Welt der
beeindruckt ihr wir schaffen das bleibt
auch wenn genau das zu vielen
merkel-muss-weg Hufen geführt hat ja und
jetzt ist sie weg nach 16 Jahren
übergibt sie das Kanzleramt an ein
Sozialdemokraten ein Abschied in der
Pandemie die starke vierte Welle das
bedrücken sie so Merkel nach der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz Krisen
Kanzlerin bis zum letzten Tag
Schlussakkord für Angela Merkel die
Kanzlerin tritt ab darüber sprechen wir
heute in der Phoenix Runde
[Musik]
Phönix Runde
die Nationalhymne beim Großen
Zapfenstreich heute Abend im
Bendlerblock zur Verabschiedung von
Angela Merkel sie hatte sich auch andere
Musik gewünscht darüber sprechen wir
dann gleich noch über ihre besonderen
Titel die auch gespielt worden sind ich
darf ich meine Gäste vorstellen Georg
Streiter ist bei uns von 2011 bis 2018
war er stellvertretender
Regierungssprecher also enger
Mitarbeiter der Kanzlerin zuvor viele
Jahre als Journalist gearbeitet unter
anderem bei der Bild-Zeitung und ich
begrüße Geld ab sie ist der deutsch
amerikanische Kabarettistin hat's
willkommen und in Hilversum in den
Niederlanden begrüße ich Sophie derxen
sie ist eine Journalistin die eine ganze
Podcast Serie über die Generation Merkel
gemacht hat schönen guten Abend nach
Hilversum
und herzlich willkommen Christoph
Schwennicke erst probiert ist und er hat
die Kanzlerschaft Merkel als Journalist
intensiv begleitet für die Süddeutsche
Zeitung für den Spiegel Cicero und jetzt
für T-Online schönen guten Abend
haben wir das vorhin gesehen den Großen
Zapfenstreich
mit Liedern wie rote Rosen soll's für
für mich soll's rote Rosen regnen ich
habe den Farbfilm vergessen aber die
Auswahl können wir ja gleich noch
sprechen mit welchem Gefühl haben sie
das gesehen dass diese Ära Merkel jetzt
zu Ende geht erstens es war very deutsch
muss ich sagen es war wenn wir sprechen
oder etwas ich muss das nur von gleichen
für mich mit Diamant Eintritt von Joe
Biden aus lady gaga die amerikanische
Nationalhymne geschmettert entscheiden
hat
aber das war sehr
VTG arme Frau Merkel ich hoffe sie hatte
irgendwie einen ein Wärmeflasche
irgendwo und unter diesem Handtuch
bedruckt irgendwie
aber natürlich irgendwie finde es auch
traurig also geht wirklich was zu Ende
ja man spürt dass das war ein sehr
harter bration war es nicht das ist
schwierig so ein Abschied in der
Pandemie es war das hat sie auch mit
Ernst ausgedrückt sie hat ja auch ein
paar Worte gesprochen wie mit welchem
Gefühl haben sie das gesehen
ja ich
war ein bisschen mit einem Gefühl es ist
geschafft auch und ich glaube auch wenn
viele das als traurig empfinden und
sozusagen schon Begräbnis Reden halten
ich glaube Angela Merkel selber ist
total zufrieden und ist mit sich völlig
im Reinen sie ist 2005 angetreten mit
den Worten ich will Deutschland dienen
und jetzt ist sie glaube ich fest davon
überzeugt und das kann sie auch sein sie
hat Deutschland 16 Jahre lang gedient
und insofern ist es dann auch gut und
zwar ohne Groll ohne Tränen es ist
einfach die Zeit ist jetzt vorbei
von Angela Merkel hat in den
Niederlanden hat Manieren Abschieds
wurde dem viel Aufmerksamkeit jetzt
geschenkt in den Niederlanden
auf jeden Fall also die Musikauswahl von
Frau Merkel ist auch hier nicht also um
unbemerkt geblieben ich war gestern zu
Gast in einem niederländischen Talkshow
Runde wo wir alle Geräte haben nach die
Motive der Motiven hinter diese
Musikauswahl
klar für viele ist natürlich Nina Hagen
auch in die Niederlande sowas wie die
godmother of punk und Angela Merkel Soli
godmother of European politics also das
hat irgendwie auch nicht richtig
zusammen gepasst deswegen würde auch
viel darüber gesprochen und z.b. gestern
würde auch in die Sonntagsrunde dann
noch mal einen Lied von Nina Hagen
gesungen von einem der niederländischen
Sängerin das war aber nur naturträne und
ich glaube es passt auch sehr gut zu die
Stimmung in den Niederlande auch hier
gibt es wird noch mal so Traurigkeit
dass sie jetzt geht wissen wir Nostalgie
sogar ok
beobachtet und haben auch sehr kritisch
gesehen mit welchem Gefühl schauen Sie
denn auf diesen Abschied jetzt sind sie
froh dass es geschafft ist
also natürlich ist das ein ergreifender
Moment gilt Haft hat gesagt ein bisschen
nüchtern und Deutsch aber trotzdem
natürlich ergreifen und man muss erstmal
sagen wer das 16 Jahre gemacht und
geschafft hat Herr Streiter hat zu Recht
gesagt wer diesen Land 16 Jahre auch
gedient hat das ist eine
außergewöhnliche Leistung das ist
erstmal zu respektieren können nur sehr
wenige Menschen physisch und psychisch
aushalten wird eine so so lange Zeit bei
der Bilanz aber da kommen die sich
Ameisen noch drauf da wäre ich dann
etwas nüchterner die halte ich am Ende
für bestenfalls durchwachsen eher
enttäuschend auch der Verweis darauf
dass sie so eine formidable Krisen
Kanzlerin war reicht mir da nicht hin
weil Krise ist das Grundrauschen der
Politik Krise ist auf einer Art immer
und regieren fängt jenseits der Krise an
und da ist mir in diesem Land in den
letzten Jahren viel zu wenig passiert
und ein paar große gravierende Fehler
würde ich auch noch benennen im Laufe
der Zeit
komme dann gleich noch so aber es war
natürlich wirklich ein Tag also mandisa
Zapfenstreich und trotzdem am Nachmittag
oder am Vormittag in die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz in dieser
schwierigen Corona Situation also dass
sie wirklich bis zum Schluss da so
arbeiten muss Herr Streiter ist das aber
auch irgendwie typisch dass sie und
dieses dienen dass es und und was
bedeutet das jetzt in dieser Pandemie
Abschied
arbeiten ich glaube sie kann auch gar
nichts anderes als arbeiten
was würden Sie sagen Freundschaft in
dieser Corona Pandemie
Wer war sie dafür sie wie hat sie diese
Krise gemeistert und
ich wünsche dass sie ein bisschen mehr
präsent sein
20/20 gesagt das ist ernst nehmen sie es
ernst Frau Dirksen schartmann aus den
Niederlanden die ja nun auch die genauso
die gleichen Probleme haben mit der
Pandemie hat man da nach Deutschland
geschaut und war Angela Merkel auch in
dir in der Pandemie eine Art Vorbild
ich glaube Niederländer waren am Anfang
auch sehr froh über die Zusammenarbeit
weil es damals auch die Möglichkeit gab
noch mal Niederländisch Patienten in
Deutschland unterbringen zu können das
ist natürlich jetzt Mission schwieriger
aber ich glaube schon in so einer
Freundin von Frau Merkel und die die
Figur dieses Jahr ist für sie ist es
schon unterschiedlich also bemerkenswert
aus niederländischen Perspektive ist
bestimmt gewesen dass sie z.b. die
Künstler auch an Anfang der Panini
zugesprochen hat und auch da noch mal
auf sagt Aufmerksamkeit darauf gelenkt
hat dass es für Künstler schwierige
Zeiten sind so was haben wir für ein von
unseren Ministerpräsident z.b. nicht
gehört und das würden sie
es gemacht hat
ja wir fangen so temperierte Lanz beim
beim Akku testen anderes ist ja auch in
Ordnung ich glaube dass ihr da wenig
Vorwürfe zu machen sind ja das ist keine
schlechte Idee finde ich von Geld Herz
gewesen da auch mal so wie es der
französische Präsident ja übrigens auch
gemacht hat in einer Sendung nach der
Tagesschau z.b. nach heute sich da
hinzusetzen an die Nation zu sprechen
aber auch wenn es so ist Vivi gerstreit
der beschreibt dass Frau Merkel sehr
geschäftsmäßig und letztlich bis Z bis
zur letzten Sekunde sehr geschäftsmäßig
vorgeht du hast in so eine Interregnum
mit dem wir jetzt waren hast du einfach
eine Macht Erosion bei der alten
Regierung und noch keine Macht bei der
neuen und dieses Interregnum hat das
Virus brutal und gnadenlos ausgenutzt
und da ist aber niemanden groß ein Tor
zu machen die Wahl war eben da und
Desinteresse um auch ist ja auch nicht
so dass die neuen Koalitionäre jetzt
fürchterlich lange er sich gesucht und
gefunden hätten
ich glaube da ist uns einfach ja sind
uns die Zeitläufte in dem Fall auf die
Füße gefallen
kann den Eindruck auch heute sogar dass
sie weil sie immer eigentlich stärkere
strengere Maßnahmen wollte
aber ich bin
mit dem öffentlichen Dienst
funktioniert nicht
[Musik]
Niedersachsen nach dass die Leitung
unterirdisch gelagert dass das
verzettelt sich das verstrickt sich und
das kann auf Dauer so nicht gut gehen
dann kann man sich forschen dass ich
gleich daneben dann doch auch ganz
erleichtert dass dass es so endet sie
hat uns was mit auf den Weg gegeben am
Schluss nämlich wie sich dieses Land
oder mit welcher Haltung wir auch das
Land irgendwie doch führen sollten wir
mal rein ich bin überzeugt dass wir die
Zukunft auch weiterhin dann gut
gestalten können wenn wir uns nicht mit
Missmut mit Missgunst mit Pessimismus
sondern wie ich vor drei Jahren in einem
anderen Rahmen gesagt habe mit
Fröhlichkeit im Herzen an die Arbeit
machen so jedenfalls habe ich immer für
mich gehalten in meinem Leben in der DDR
und erst recht und umso mehr unter den
Bedingungen der Freiheit
es ist diese Fröhlichkeit im Herzen die
ich uns allen und im übertragenen Sinne
unserem Land auch für die Zukunft
wünsche ich danke Ihnen von Herzen
Fröhlichkeit im Herzen und schöne Worte
Frau Tufts und man hat das sehr bei
ihrer Liederauswahl da mehr auf am
Anfangs drüber gesprochen es gab dieses
lied die sind DDR Schlager von Nina
Hagen von unseren 74 du hast den
Farbfilm vergessen da hat sie viele mit
überrascht weil das war so eine
fröhliche Seite die man eigentlich bei
ihr oft nicht so gesehen hat in der
Umgebung finden Sie das mit der
Fröhlichkeit im Herz
rockversion heute Abend gespielt und
Jungs aber bisschen anders aber auch
Hildegard Knef
entschuldigung aber die Punk Zeit von
Nina Hagen war wesentlich später dass du
noch keine Bank und Santander
klassenchat
durch wie witzig Frau Merkel ist das ist
eine Seite von ihr sie trennt das sehr
aber in privat ist sie sehr witzig ist
sie sehr diese Bodenständigkeit deswegen
auf meinem scheidereiter wie wird sich
ist von Merkel
Herr Schwennicke ich sage da liegt auch
ein Hase im Pfeffer weil das stimmt
natürlich auf Streiter hat es wesentlich
intensiver noch miterlebt als ich es als
Korrespondent konnte aber sie hat einen
sehr ausgeprägten Mutterwitz und ist im
direkten Kontakt tatsächlich sehr sehr
einnehmend durch diese durch diese
Schlagfertigkeit um dieses diesen
spontanen Witz und diesen ganzen
trockenen Witz den sie hat das hat in
meinen Augen und dann würde ich jetzt an
Rosen sind ja bekanntlich auch Dornen
würde ich jetzt bei den roten Rosen ein
bisschen auf die Daunen auch hinweisen
oder mal die die Dornen seinen ebenfalls
das hat dazu geführt was sie meinen
Augen jedenfalls über viele Jahre sehr
sehr milde gesehen wurde weil sie
einfach sehr einnehmend im Wesen ist und
auch nicht nur Regierungssprecher
anderer Parteien keiner war so ein
glühender Regierungssprecher
von Angela Merkel die der den eigentlich
die SPD entsandt hatte Thomas Steg und
Herr Streiter würde glaube ich auch
nicht bestreiten dass dass sie ihm
imponiert hat und das hat sie vier und
Co denn auch und diese persönliche
Neigung hatte meine Begriffe insgesamt
die Amtszeit und die Politik von Frau
Merkel in etwas hier mildes Licht
getaucht bin ich wenn ich zwei Vorgänger
Kanzler nehme wir lassen es mal die
Wiedervereinigung hätten die spielt
sozusagen in der anderen Liga und die
ist eher außen vor aber da sind schon
andere Erbschaften hinterlassen worden
von Helmut Kohl und auch von Gerhard
Erler
was hat die alle warum haben die alle so
positiv über Frau Merkel
ich glaube für die Niederländer also
mein Heimatland sich natürlich am besten
einschätzen kann da sieht man sehr
deutlich das ist unter jüngere jüngere
Niederländer
vorübergehend eine sehr positive
Bewertungen von Merkel gab z.b. würde
hier ein Elektro Opa gemacht von junge
Schauspieler über Frau Merkel wo sie ihr
auch gefeiert haben als die letzte igolo
also Politiker politische Figur ohne Ego
sozusagen die haben sich Sorgen gemacht
über das Position vacuum was sie da
hinterlassen würde
das sieht man sehr stark natürlich dass
man sie gerade als Krisen Kanzlerin wie
schon erwähnt wahrgenommen wird dass sie
mit einem gewissen Ruhe verbunden
Wertstabilität Bodenständigkeit also
alle Soares Foto kulturelle Sachen klar
für die Niederländer Niederländer geht
auch noch in protestantische Frau
liberal geprägtes Land wir hatten
niemals eine eine frauliche so eine
starke Frau in in der Kritik an der
Leitung des Landes also das heißt ja ist
alles ist alles vorübergehend wichtig
gewesen für viele Niederländer ich fand
es aber wichtig um auch die Diskrepanz
zwischen die internationale Perspektive
auf Frau Merkel und auch dann die die
mir innerdeutsche Perspektive
weiterzugeben deswegen habe ich in
meinem Podcast drei auch sehr viele
junge deutsche danach gefragt wie sie
eigentlich gerade diese politische
Erbschaft von Frau Merkel bewerten und
gibt es gab es dann viele negative
Stimmen auch
ich glaube schon also gerade ist
natürlich die Frage
politisch hat sie die Status Quo
verkörpert und wie gesagt ich habe mit
einer deutsche Journalistin gesprochen
die meinte es gab so gewiss eine
heimliche Liebe vielleicht für merke
auch wenn man politisch nicht ganz mit
dir einverstanden war dann haben wir uns
doch irgendwie verbunden gefühlt aber
man sehnt auch richtig nach auf
natürlich da sede legale bekommen
Frage ist er sie hat ja auch sehr viel
Hass hervorgerufen er schreit das gerade
ja unglaubliche ihr Hassbotschaften und
diese merkel muss weg rufe die gerade in
diesem Flüchtling Sommer 2015 so massiv
wurden wie ist die damit umgekommen und
wie umgegangen und wie erklären Sie sich
diesen die das lied dass diese kühle
Frau so viel Emotionen hervor ihrem
konnte
das damit hatte sie nicht gerechnet und
sag mal so sie war es gewohnt dass Leute
gegen die sind oder sowas da hat
überhaupt kein Problem mit ja aber dass
das wirklich blanker Hass und nackte
gewaltiger entgegenschlagen das hat sie
glaube ich richtig tief getroffen und
verunsichert und
und daraus ist aber natürlich auch einen
gegen Wut Erwachsenen also sie ist dann
auch sehr robust dagegen vorgegangen und
sie hat ja dann auch bei Veranstaltungen
wenn sie solchen Leuten dann begegnet
ist sie in Wien war das mal den die hat
die dann ja auch mal wirklich in den
Senkel gestellt und gesagt also da war
doch mal diese eine Frage wohl irgendwie
in Wien oder Zürich wo irgend eine
Zuschauerin fragte wie sie die
Islamisierung Europas sieht und hat sie
gesagt wann waren sie eingesetzt in
meiner Kirche also da hat sie dann noch
mal Kraft ausgeschöpft und dagegen wie
man das erklären kann ich weiß es nicht
ich weiß es nicht
das ja mal gesagt im Angela Merkel seid
ihr Mutter der AFD durch ihr Verhalten
haben sie die AFD möglich gemacht und
sieht es und warum sehen Sie das so
hier in dieser
Hilfsaktion für den ersten
Flüchtlingstreck der sich aufgemacht
hatte sondern in der anschließenden
Politik die schon was mit
Kontrollverlust und damit auch
Vertrauensverlust zu tun hatte zumal
gerade Frau Merkel und die CDU jahrelang
vorhergesagt haben und behauptet haben
Deutschland sei kein Einwanderungsland
und wenn ich dann auf diese Art und
Weise Einwanderung herbeiführen und zu
lasse dann haben Teile der Bevölkerung
damit ein sehr großes Problem und
übrigens bis heute wenn sie sich auf den
etwas sagen wir mal sumpfige Rennzeiten
auf den sumpfigen Portalen in den
Kommentarspalten rumtreiben und ist
einfach mal anschauen dann wird auch
jetzt bei diesem bei diesem
Corona bei dieser Corona Skepsis
gegenüber der Corona Politik der
Bundesregierung immer wieder auf 215
rekurriert da ist in meinen Augen
tatsächlich was zu Bruch gegangen und
deswegen werde ich da auch nicht müde zu
sein das war nicht gut ich gut gemanagt
übrigens auch nicht zu Europa und auch
nicht für die CDU und CDU ist auch zum
Teil deswegen da
weil Angela Merkel zum Teil Fehler
gemacht hat bei der SPD war es ja was ja
so da würde ich sagen hat Gerhard
Schröder und mit der Agenda 2010 dem
Land wirklich einen großen Dienst
erwiesen das hat Frau Merkel fairerweise
bei der Amtsübergabe ihm ja auch
wirklich konzentriert sie haben sich um
dieses Land verdient gemacht weil es
Zitat und hier würde ich sagen ist das
nicht der Fall Gerhard Schröder ist
damals für diesen Verdienst am Land von
seiner Partei auch geächtet worden mehr
oder weniger die CDU ist jetzt an der
Politik von Frau Merkel zum Teil auch
ein wenig mindestens mal zerbröselt die
muss ich jetzt erst die muss ich erstmal
wieder finden die haben durch ir
Schröder hat
sie hat Gerd Schröder hat eine große
Reform hinterlassen Frau Merkel hat
keine große Reform hinterlassen aber
Frau Merkel hat sich damit im Ausland
auch auf dem doch auch vieles ja eine
hohe Ansehen erworben Ortschaft Zwiebeln
sie sagen
[Musik]
großer Pluspunkt für Frau Merkel obwohl
er Politik
vielleicht war er hat etwas zu tun mit
die AFD Reaktion von Reutte nach einem
Jahr mindestens sie war nicht wie Trump
hey ich bin die AFD die
ganze Welt nicht nur hier in Deutschland
sie hat nicht die Flammen weitergefeiert
wen sie die Trump mit was am 6. Januar
von Anita bei der Capitol gemacht hat
und diese unterschied auch in diese
Zeiten
Cinema sie war
sie war die Erwachsene die bodenständige
die
man irgendwie vertrauen könnte und die
sich irgendwie mit diesem Machos
arrangieren
große sie war nicht hysterisch sie war
nicht dramatisch wenn sie war nicht so
kalt wie eine Frau Winter
ohnmächtige Frau haben wir zu
vergleichen da hat schon da war sie
nicht ich finde diese Ernas für mich ist
das beste von Deutschland wenn ich sage
dass die ceremony heute sehr deutsch war
Frau Merkel auch sehr deutscher nein
wegen des ich liebe Deutschland dafür
diese Bodenständigkeit dieser Schritt
für Schritt dieser wir schaffen das
auch wenn wir das nicht schaffen in
diesem Moment dass sie das gesagt hat
habe ich geheult anders hat mich
wirklich berührt und und irgendwie doof
deutsch Mannschaft das hier sind ja
heute abend okay
wie ist das für sie als
junge Europäerinnen wenn sie sind
Flüchtlinge
Merkel wir schaffen das ist das
sozusagen ist das ein moralischer
Kompass der der über Deutschland hinaus
zeigt oder ist es
letztendlich keine gute europäischen
scheitern auch der europäischen
Flüchtlingspolitik die haben wir ja auch
gesehen
ich glaube aber dort genau zu diesem
Thema Migration liegt liegt im großen
Diskrepanz zwischen die internationale
Perspektive auf Merkel und ihr
innerdeutsch gesehen würde ich sagen
also klar auch für viele Niederländer
spielt mit das Vermerke immer wieder
verbunden wird mit diesem wir schaffen
das diesen moralischen Kompass wird sie
da was sie damals gezeigt hat ich glaube
glaube das ist aber weniger bekannt ist
was natürlich nachher passiert ist und
dass sie auch nachher z.b. nach der
Kölner Silvesternacht ein sehr faires
trägt die Ware als EU Politik geführt
hat solche Signale kommen dann eher
weniger durch deswegen glaube ich schon
dass es immer noch deswegen sehr stark
mit mit mit ihr verbunden wird diese
moralische Geste damals
und trotzdem gibt es natürlich auch sehr
viele auch weiter in Europa die auch das
Scheitern der europäischen
Migrationspolitik er hat doch auch mit
Frau Merkel verbindet ist ihr leider
nicht gelungen da wirklich eine
nachhaltige Lösung zu finden also die
große Europäerin Herr Schwennicke ist
die dann letztendlich nicht oder
Bussi von viel europäische Länder so
gesehen wird aber
ich meine dass die Kollegin gerade
gesagt hat ist ja richtig dass das ist
hier stark bejubelt wurde von den
Nachbarländern aber die Verteilung von
der Frau Merkel ja in mehreren Sendungen
bei Anne Will da hat sie ja mehrere
Soloauftritte zwei mindestens mal an
kurz hintereinander wo sie gesagt hat so
jetzt sind die eben da und jetzt
verteilen wir die innerhalb von Europa
der hat ja nicht stattgefunden also ich
muss immer etwas schmunzeln wenn er
Asselborn aus Luxemburg der
Außenminister der so ein ganz charmant
ist deutsch spricht im Deutschlandfunk
morgens immer von der europäischen
Migrationspolitik spricht Luxemburg hat
überhaupt niemanden davon aufgenommen
also da da klappen natürlich dann reden
und handeln auch weit auseinander und zu
mal aber natürlich auch die Ansichten
darüber innerhalb der Europäischen Union
sehr sehr unterschiedlich waren ich
verweise jetzt mal auch auf die
Osteuropäer hat das in meinen Augen
jedenfalls was frau Merkel gemacht hat
Europa schlicht und ergreifend nicht gut
getan das war
unbedacht und ich muss ganz oft denken
wir hatten sie einmal zu einem
salongespräch bei Sitzungen im Berliner
Ensemble und dann habe ich sie gefragt
warum wir bauen Ding ist ja ein zu
langen Erfahrung bringen sie manche zur
Weißglut bis sie endlich entscheiden und
dann sagte sie ich muss erst zu Ende
gedacht haben bis ich entscheide das war
ein toller Satz der ganze Zahl hat
gelacht es war eine wunderbare brannte
die Frage ist nur was ist und die Frage
ist halt erst hinter eingefallen als als
es vorbei war dieses salongespräch was
ist wenn es die Zeit nicht hat lange
nachzudenken wenn ich mir die
Entscheidungen an schau Dich kritisch
sehe dann waren es immer spontan
Entscheidungen Energiewende
Flüchtlingspolitik und ich habe den
Eindruck dass sie beim lange nachdenken
gute Politik macht aber da wo es auf
Spontanität ankommt mehr auf dem Bauch
als als im Kopf als auf den Kopf da ist
es eher schief gegangen wenn Sie das
unterstützen
gesagt dass er jetzt ist dass ich nach
dem flüchtigen Budapest Ungarn über
Österreich nach Deutschland kam es gab
überhaupt keine andere Alternative ja es
war die einzige Möglichkeit alles was
dann
kritisieren ist oder zu Recht oder zu
Unrecht ist dann später geschehen aber
da gab es überhaupt keine Alternative
und man kann ja auch nicht vorwerfen
dass sie keine Europäer dann sei bloß
weil die anderen Europäer jetzt keine
Lust hatten Flüchtlinge aufzunehmen ja
das kann man hier ja nicht vornehmen und
ich war werfen und ich weiß sie hat dich
an dem Wochenende die Finger wund
telefoniert ja und ist halt überall von
Schrubber gelaufen weil weil so sind
Menschen ganz fremde wollen wir hier
nicht haben um Gottes Willen ja so also
da hast du sicher
ist sie halt irgendwie
weder für die CDU noch für Frau Merkel
sprechen aber ehrlich gesagt muss ich
sagen es ist doch mir sogar fast noch
recht das ist die AFD gibt ja weil diese
Leute sind jetzt identifizierbar die
haben Gesichter die haben Namen und das
ist mir lieber die sind mit ein paar
Prozent im Bundestag als wenn sie sich
in einer irgendwie großen CDU verstecken
als als rechter Flügel also
gut
[Musik]
geschafft
das auch so und es gibt immer noch
keinen in dem Stern Quote sein aber
gucken wir die CEO Wärme sollte drei
Männer um den CDU Vorsitz das
sehe ich nicht außer das
die sie da war
von diesem
hier das finde ich auf einer Seite nicht
schlecht weil das ist bestimmt
ganz bestimmt
ich glaube schon klar also die Tatsache
dass vormerken eine Frau ist also als
Führungsfigur Figur ist natürlich super
wichtig für sehr viele junge Frauen
gewesen trotzdem muss ich sagen dass ich
auch während meiner research auch sehr
viele junge deutsche Frauen gesprochen
habe auch außer z.b. außerhalb ihrer
eigener Partei aus der CDU die doch auch
sich gewünscht hätten dass Frau Merkel
sich da ein bisschen früher schon
geoutet hätte als Feministin wie sie es
dann letztendlich im September noch mal
gemacht hat also ich glaube schon dass
es da auch international klar ist gibt's
diesen Bild von Frau Merkel als mächtige
Figur als Frau aber trotzdem inhaltlich
glaube ich gibt es da auch noch wirklich
Nachholbedarf mal gucken ob sie das war
ja vielleicht mit diesem
das war ganz wichtig das hätte sich
vielleicht mal solche Signale hätte sich
im Laufe ihrer Amtszeit gleich häufiger
senden können
das hätte da manches vielleicht etwas
versöhnlicher gemacht aber das ist halt
nicht so ihr Ding also sie sie trägt
ihre Emotionen nicht nach außen und das
kann sie nicht und man kann sie auch
nicht dazu zwingen und
aus dem DDR diese Ruhe dieser innerer
Stralsund sage ich immer dass das
brauchen wir in Amerika und und sie hat
es gegeben auch zu dieser diese Männer
in America in diesem bestimmte Zeiten
auch in deren Amtszeit des war nicht
immer leicht für den und ich glaube sie
hat die doch ein bisschen
bevor du mindestens sie ist
okay sie hat ja mal einen Kampf gemacht
mit sie kennen mich
Merkel eigentlich
dass wir sie kennen
sie in Wahrheit
kennen Sie vielleicht sogar
ich glaube übrigens dass ihr ihr Ehemann
Herr Sauer und nichts mit dem Satz zu
Corona die Deutschen sind so ein
bisschen faul dass das auch dabei eine
Rolle spielt man wird es dann wieder sie
kennen mich wir kennen die wir wählen
die wieder das ist hier so für insofern
auch
hier zum Vorteil gereicht die
problematische Seite dieses sie kennen
mich ist ja ja auch in diesem Wort Mutti
mit drin dass man sagt ja ich mache das
schon für euch das ist ja so die die die
Botschaft und da würde ich eben es tut
mir leid ich muss es ja noch mal
anzusagen manches ist eben einfach auch
nicht gemacht worden also wenn selbst
der jetzige Oppositionschef Herr
Brinkhaus von der CDU schon in
Wahlkampfzeiten also schon vor dem
Verlust der Macht für die CDU gesagt hat
mich dieses Land sieht echt alt aus wir
haben Modernisierung der Verwaltung
Digitalisierung einfach nicht
vorangebracht dann ist das z.b. ein Teil
der wirklich liegen geblieben ist und
mit diesem sie kennen nicht haben wir
uns alle würde ich ein bisschen
einlullen lassen und auch zuwenig
eingefordert es gibt ja dieses schöne
werkeln
das gibt's ja auch nicht von ungefähr
Streiter das Merkel ich habe das noch
nie gehört
[Gelächter]
du hast schon immer so viel zu essen
gibt ja das ist
Frau Merkel wirklich also das finde ich
immer schon alliston auch immer total
schön und faszinierend wann man kann
immer wieder weiter red sollen
und er gesprochen hat als beispielsweise
Wladimir Putin den hat sie natürlich
erst starken Widersacher wahrgenommen
zugleich hat er sie enorm fasziniert und
es war ein großer Reiz für Sie diese
Person in ihrer sozialen in ihrer
Situation zu zu
erfassen also wenn ich zu scannen
regelrecht ab zu scannen und dann zu
sehen was kann ich da realistischerweise
hinkriegen und das ist Merkel und sehen
war ja auch sie konnte gut russischer
kann gut russisch das war ja nun
wirklich ein Vorteil im Verhältnis zu
Putin in der Außenpolitiker Streiter was
denken Sie was was was hinterlässt sie
da oder was wird da jetzt fehlen
[Musik]
dann über 16 Jahre und
da ist jetzt eine echte Lücke ja auch
wenn man also ich meine das war aber
immer ihr auch mit Erdogan und Putin mit
mit all diesen Leuten hatte ich immer so
gehalten dass sie dir einfach als
existent anerkannt hat und gesagt hat
okay die Leute haben Sie gewiss sie sind
da sind die etwas nicht durch einen
Militärputsch an die Macht gekommen
sondern sind gewählt worden wie auch
immer und sie sind da und wir müssen
irgendwie damit umgehen und dieser
Pragmatismus
fernab von jeglicher Empörung Lyrik oder
so die bringt man ja auch nicht weiter
so und also aber das ist wirklich ein
Problem dass der Westen keinen keine
Telefon Gesprächspartner mehr für Putin
hat
Strandkorb Stralsund irgendwo einfach
die Füße hochlegen und ein bisschen
chillen
[Gelächter]
es gibt doch durch dieses schöne Bilder
wo sie immer da im im berglift heißt es
nach sitzt ich wünsche dass sie glaube
ich da in Südtirol
Ruhe findet wenn sie da mal hin fährt
ich finde auch diese diese schöne Satz
da auch noch eben im Wald meinem
Hildegard Knef vom vom Lied ich würde
mich gern mal Fan vom alten neu
entfalten ne also das ist gibt
vielleicht doch auch noch ein Hinweis
dass sie noch was vor hat also ich bin
sehr gespannt was passiert als wären sie
was sie macht
also ich würde sagen sie hat ja immer
die Macht war ihr sehr wichtig aber die
Insignien der Macht waren ihr ziemlich
schnuppe das heißt sie kann sehr gut auf
alldem das Drumherum auf rote Teppiche
und große Autos und alles mögliche ein
großer Entourage auf kann sie glaube ich
ganz gut verzichten jedoch
ja mache ich aber sieht aber die die
Tätigkeit schon dann ganz kurzen Herr
Streiter was glauben sie hat irgendwie
überraschen also sie wird erstmal die
muss erstmal wirklich ich muss ich ja
wirklich mal ganz kurz ein bisschen
erholen und mal wieder Luft kriegen und
so aber nach einer kurzen Zeit mit
irgendwas Überraschung
vielen Dank für das Gespräch
[Musik]